56 cameras hooked up by us be taking
simultaneous photos of anything that's
put inside of it and then output into a
3d object now this is awesome because in
years past any 3d objects that you
wanted to make had to be taken with
multiple cameras at various different
times or even using laser scanning
slowly spinning around whatever is put
inside of it now in just 30 seconds you
can step inside this booth and have an
output file that can then be printed
into your very own action figure let's
go check this out
that was a really crazy experience this
right here is the closest that I've ever
been to being inside the matrix you know
the part in matrix 3 when Keanu meets
Colonel Sanders in that white room with
the screens that keep flipping around as
soon as you go in there in the triggers
start the shutters go from one side of
your head and they spin around to the
other and the next thing you know you
got your own action figure now if you
want to build one of these yourself and
you don't have 56 cameras you can
actually build your own rig with a
single camera off of the Autodesk
Instructables page and then go to the
software one two 3d app calm